triangle in equality theorem tells us is
that any two sides in a triangle have to
be greater than the third side so when
you add any two sides together they have
to be more than the third if they're not
you would get a scenario like this where
say for example this was four and this
was five and this is ten see even if you
were to rotate these sides down they're
not going to be long enough to span that
distance of 10 units right so any two
sides have to actually be greater if we
had a triangle like this where this is
four and say this is seven and this is
ten now I can see four plus seven is 11
that's greater than ten so any of the
two sides the sum of the two sides has
to be more than the third side so I'll
show you how to do this in this problem
what you do in this algebraic example is
you would take any two sides say for
example 2x plus 1 plus 4x minus 7
has to be greater than the third side
which is X plus 1 but we also have to
take into account that 2x plus 1 plus X
plus 1 those two sides have to be
greater than 4x minus 7 and also we have
4x minus 7 plus X plus 1 has to be
greater than 2x plus 1 okay so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna solve
these three inequalities separately and
then we're going to take a look at the
solutions on the number line to find out
what the possible values of X are in
order to make this a true triangle so a
possible triangle that you can draw so
let's go ahead and solve this 2x plus 4
X is 6 X positive 1 and negative 7 is a
negative 6 and here what I'm going to do
is I'm going to subtract X from both
sides so that's going to be 5x I'm going
to add 6 to both sides that's going to
give us 7 and if we divide both sides by
5 you can see that X is going to be
greater than 7 fists that's one
constraint now over here we're going to
solve this gives us 3x 1 plus 1 is 2
here if I let's see subtract 4x that's
going to be negative 1x if I subtract 2
from both sides that's going to give us
negative 9 if I divide both sides by
negative 1 whenever you multiply or
divide both sides by a negative
where the inequality sign flips or
changes direction and then the third
inequality we have 4x plus 1 X is 5x
negative 7 and positive 1 is negative 6
here if I subtract 2x from both sides we
get 3x and if I add 6 to both sides we
get 7 if I divide both sides by 3 to get
X by itself we have X is greater than
7/3 so I think that part you're probably
pretty familiar with but this part here
is what tricks students a little bit
what you want to do is you want to plot
these on the number line from lowest to
greatest so the smallest number here
looks like it's going to be seven fifths
okay seven fifths is like one and two
fists let's see the next largest is
going to be 7/3 which is actually like
two and one-third so that's going to be
right about here let's just say 7/3
and then over here nine is the largest
that's nine okay so we want X to be
greater than seven fifths so greater
than means to the right we want it to be
greater than 7/3 okay and we want X to
be less than nine okay so now we've
graphed all three of those on the number
line what you want to look for is that
overlapping regions so here you can see
if you're over here between seven fifths
and seven thirds you know two of the
constraints are satisfied by not this
third constraint etc so what you want to
do is look at where they're overlapping
so you can see they're overlapping right
here in this region in between 7/3 and
nine so as long as X is greater than 7/3
and at the same time less than nine
basically sandwiched in between seven
thousand nine then this is going to
actually be a triangle that you can you
can draw meaning that any two sides will
have some more than the third side we
won't have a situation here where
there's a gap etc so great job you're
new to the channel you like my teaching
style I'll have a link below in the
description for an organized list of
videos by math subject like algebra
algebra 2 precalculus etc also by
chapter so covering similar topics so if
you're interested go ahead and check
that link down below otherwise subscribe
to the channel and I'll look forward to
seeing in the future video
I'll talk to you soon